i'm like 150 and nepal's like 10 so he's
we're we're like on different planets
basically
i'm a mere mortal he's a god
[Music]
live in the moment here if that's okay
with people
this is you don't get this opportunity
every day you know
yeah let's go night this move feels
wrong but on the other hand
i mean how wrong could it be to get this
knight to such a beautiful square
well if i take he's got to take with the
g pawn
here we can send his queen back
given that he can't play yeah and now we
can get this queen around
it's a g3
if he goes knight g6 i will simply go h5
um
okay there he wants f4 that makes
perfect sense
queen f3 is probably a better idea but
then bishop c6 he starts to resist
what do i do here well i can actually
just take maybe
uh
that was a very very nice game i need to
go to the bathroom of course i
immediately need to pee
as soon as we start the match but it's
okay i'll play one more and then
let's play here
old man has some punches left to deliver
this is um an interesting line i mean i
don't know the theory but i know this is
kind of fashionable
now knight f6 is the idea that's all i
know
and now so d5 is interesting d6 maybe
yeah but then he takes and goes g4 let's
think d5 there should be 5
you do something so d6g4
d5 g5 it's also kind of interesting
yeah but now d5
g5 maybe i'll just sack the knight
honestly it's not so clear his king is
super weak there
yeah let's go sack the knight here it's
a bit crazy but
i mean his king is super super weak
queen g5 maybe queen d6 or even queen d4
is interesting
but queen d6 okay
well i don't think nepo's breaking
anything i've beaten him before it's not
so
so out of the realm of possibility that
i beat someone pretty good in the
game particularly since i did play a
nice game that game i mean it wasn't
like
he was winning
but yeah to lose to me is extremely
depressing
it's the lowest it's the lowest you can
possibly descend
i'm kidding
yeah but now he's probably just winning
okay let's get the queen out
let's hope he plays 94 but he won't
so the thing is okay now i need to start
attacking him on the queen side i have
to
like made him somehow quickly
i'm actually not a super gym but thanks
i mean i appreciate it when people call
me that but it's not true
i'm like 150 and nepal's like 10 so he's
we're like on different planets
basically
i'm a mere mortal he's a god that's
that's the best
translation of this okay so let's try d3
it's rating a few day rating of 2700 or
more
he's number four in the world it's a
huge honor to be even
playing him in any kind of match
[ __ ] you should be higher than 150
yes that's a very constructive thing to
say thank you
okay let's take but again i appreciate
people saying that but
it is what it is
i'm 168. i'm basically in the gutter
ladies and gentlemen i've scammed you
you you all been thinking i'm pretty
decent but no
oh my god i have a beaut i have an uh an
idea but it doesn't work what am i doing
um this doesn't work either i think
you can just play rookie one right
wait a minute no actually it's not so
clear
but he plays bishop takes d3 mother
effer
i'm a rapper
okay so bishop d3 rookie one
hmm is there really nothing here
i mean i could go i suppose
let's think
so close to having a really beautiful
idea here but no
oh whatever let's do it let's do it
i have an idea that definitely doesn't
work but it's really cool i want to sack
the queen
and now i want to go here now he has d4
that's the reason it doesn't work
but even after d4 i have an attack
and i feel like it's actually not that
easy for him to defend
against this attack although
i'm sure he has a defense here but i'm
gonna make him make him sweat a little
bit
yeah that was close no cigar
i mean that was cool
okay nebo castles again i might do a
great gift around him
yeah this time he doesn't
that was a really pretty pretty idea but
it's i knew i knew it didn't work
i was already lost though to be fair
now white is better here i mean this is
not a great line for black i think
the idea is to go c4 the thing is i
analyzed this from black's perspective
so i actually for a change
know what to do
of course most of my ideas are on sound
but that's the fun part about being
being who i am is just
i'm not pretending to be someone i'm not
just i'm just a normal guy having some
fun
okay let's go b5
i needed to go to the toilet but i'm
playing nepal so i can wait
i mean the more we talk about it the
more i want to be so
i'll pee after this game i'll switch to
my phone
okay so bishop g2 knight g2
i can go queen g4 there i think
should be winning oh but bishop f6 is
amazing
amaze me no but still winning yeah
alex thank you
all right guys
let's let's just enjoy the match shall
we
good oh my god i wondered
yeah but it's not so clear yes
okay let's think i forgot that that was
there
but okay maybe it's still good for me i
don't know we should be five uh but he's
got queen c5 amazing
bishop p7 rook f2 takes
knight t3 it's a crazy position he's got
like all the time in the world here
yeah it's just winning for him i guess
although i guess i have
i think i have a draw
i think i have a draw but i'm not sure
super complex
yeah i was definitely winning there at
some point
definitely winning there so wait what if
i take no no that doesn't work
i can also take here but then he goes to
rook f7
i mean it's just amazing these guys have
so many lives
i mean he can't he he has to go for the
draw he cannot go king
there's just no way he can oh he does
there's just no way this can work but
okay i can draw with this one i think
but he wants to goad me into something
more untoward
yeah he wants me to check him on g5
which would be wrong
oh it's still not a draw repeated like
800 times
yeah that was a very interesting game
wilfred harris thank you i'm pretty sure
i was winning at some point but
okay
yeah and that part of the king's gambit
which i don't really know how to play
against to be honest
it's been a while
my idea is to carve out the d5 square
here just put the knight there
but here i should be able to take but
also okay
so the question is i guess there is no
question i should
i probably should take it
and then go c6 56.
i meant to believe it should be six
first now he's got bishop c4
i meant to believe it should be six
first
yeah that was a big big mistake by me
that's all it takes is one mistake
against someone like him
still it's it's not like horrible for me
i guess
the problem with some of these top
players is they they kind of tend to get
pissed at like match interruptions and
stuff so i'm gonna
go while i'm playing
even if you need to go to the toilet
i'm serious i'm actually dead serious
like it is sometimes a problem
i'm not saying nepa would have an issue
but i have
let's just say played certain people who
were not too keen on me going to the
bathroom
during the match but this is just losing
that's a very bad game
or was it because i have queen b2
threatening mate wait a second
i guess he goes queen h3 but then i go
rook h6
and it's still still holding on there
okay but now i take yeah he goes just
beat g3
that's the issue
i guess i go here this is definitely bad
though
i think certain people from charlotte
are still up
i don't know some some some idiots
what do i do here so queen f2
check
wow that's actually an amazing idea he
goes king of two later though
wow it doesn't work it's losing
incredible
well what if i go there maybe yeah the
problem is also how fast he plays
not only is he much better than me he's
also much faster
yeah that was nice
well the audio is off because my
headphones are charging
whoa lion pride gift in the five that's
what we're talking about thank you lion
pride gifting five
subs to the community thank you so much
appreciate aligned pride 83
loving the hype
yeah this is complicated
but now here
i want to go out five and just blast it
blast it through
just want a blast to the queen h4 i'll
move my queen
probably to f3 although let's think
yeah i mean the
on the flip side queen e2
so let's let's think about this or
something queen f3 maybe he has some f5
ideas
queen e2 i can also play bishop
snakes no hmm
this is very complicated i want to get
this right
yeah i have a feeling queenie 2 is
probably better
thank you for the another 500 bits
thank you sir thank you sir
oh this is not so clear actually it's
not like completely winning or anything
so
probably a bad move
maybe it's time for f5 yeah
glad you like it welcome
okay what does he do here
bishop c8 bishop g5 is very strong
yeah not too much longer guys i am
feeling the
exhaustion can't take it
you probably yeah he takes
take sticks so g3 what does he have
oh g3 queen g4 d e yeah but that's
winning
let's get this freaking move
um
two pieces up ladies and gentlemen two
pieces up
okay this time we're playing something
real
yeah h4 is a new move let's go h5 looks
like they play
these days
you can take them
it's complicated
yeah but he's gonna go like here
probably just crush me knight c7 is a
big threat
shouldn't have shouldn't have done that
because this is also hanging
sadly sag
i guess i can take maybe it's like not
that bad
a4 bishop c4
somewhere here i met him as judgment
still like i this these positions are
usually winnable
g4 i'll go h4
bishop c4 yeah
yeah but now i'll castle
you gotta go here force
yeah i got a decent position here
actually
what text check check
[Music]
i don't get it
just don't see it i don't see it
i just don't see it what's the idea i
mean first of all i can go here
yeah i guess the idea is just to get a
huge attack going so probably i should
okay but if i go here he's gonna go like
queen up he's gonna try to put
yeah so i should probably go here
i shouldn't chicken out
this is going to be hard to play with
like a minute
24 probably
so
um
i'll block you there again you know
jeff's definitely
definitely losing at some point
it's a weird weird move
oh he took it this way wow castled long
jesus
really really
i guess he wants f5 but that doesn't
really work
he still wants it
i need to go to the bathroom really
badly
no i'm doing okay
my brain is like a sieve
so what happens when you're tired
this is bad yeah this end game isn't
it's not gonna end well but it's fine
really thought i have this in the e5
this can get dangerous for him
i mean i don't know
i love these discussions
okay so probably rookie five is better
even though fv looks good
but i should take with the rook because
peace activity is the most important
thing in the end game
my eye is going to go
but now this
do
that's wrong that was bad
okay i don't know how this goes
really really
first
and maybe some you can just you can
enjoy the match
i know
what's in here
thank you don't tell maria i'm not don't
worry i won't tell maria you stopped
he wants takes for sure d3 it's a nice
idea
but does it work i don't think it does
no it doesn't we've got a five if he
does that
see he's trying to confuse me
he probably succeeded
really riley really riley
really riley
lexington thanks for the tier one
maybe slightly better for white
okay so it seems prudent to improve the
position of the knight
yeah ed is actually interesting
but probably f3 i mean ah but then uh
this hangs that's not good
at all that's not good at all
a knight d4 maybe should be sounding
okay so let's go here
all right fine we'll take it i mean
riley is charlotte
this is charlottism
he had queen f6 winning a piece actually
and that's pretty funny
he could have won a piece there
and that won the game okay now i can
defend at least yeah i screwed this up
but
this shouldn't be too bad for me if i'm
very careful
three
it's just bad play
very bad play
thank you sam bram ziv
thank you
yeah bad bad bad bad
i mean my chin is up i'm beating nepo
seven three
but i i'm not satisfied when i play at
the same time
i mean
let's go here now this is lost
i need to find chances here
i need to create i need to create
chances somehow
i'm holding it in
that's a bit of a weird move
wow that's winning
all right maybe last couple
let's go here
b5
okay there's no real threats here so i
can also just take on b3
probably i should
just get that knight out of there bishop
out of there
yeah this is nasty
how bad is this i don't know
yeah he's got a good night against a bad
bishop situation but my bishop can also
be activated like i don't know
i don't think this is that bad
and what do i know about these positions
nothing
okay i'm gonna seek my fortunes in the
sun game
and i'm gonna try to get around to my
king
hmm you may have screwed this up
actually
now it's not so clear yeah but he finds
the freaking defense
incredible knight f3 you can do four
hmm it's quite amazing maybe i should go
d4
no that's a bad idea
yeah this is losing sadly
i think
make your chest dojo love damn girl
rating party
40 thank you david appreciate it
where is he going
now i'm probably going to decline a draw
because he might end up in zug's lung of
some sort
she just did
he's absolutely busted here i think
might be a draw actually
no it's lost
putting that in a freaking textbook
all right
that was finally a good one from the
coach
he's gonna sack his exchange at some
point but it's fine i mean i can't
really avoid this
it's gonna probably do something like
this no oh he just has this and what am
i doing
i have knight two i actually honestly
forgot about this move
damn that's an annoying one
that was a very costly blender
okay let's just go here and i guess i'll
just go back to f4 and
okay i don't think this is like that bad
actually
just how we are in charlotte
squared up a peg again
crap yeah i had a great position there
out of the opening but
i absolutely botched it
yeah i should go to sleep guys i'm
starting to really feel exhausted
maybe we'll play to 15 games
and of course he'll be mad and
everything but it's also 4 30.
can't satisfy everybody
grand master gary though thank you for
the radar i appreciate it
playing nepo thank you gary
and i'm losing to nippo
i have very bad games here this game was
bad
particular
hmm i guess i have to take
that was nicely played by him
c4
okay i like playing against this line
feel confident here
okay let's just develop
positional try to carve out that square
for myself
wow very bold play laos knight t4
i mean i could go here and then try to
checkmate him i mean that's not a bad
idea probably
and then maybe just freaking go for it
i mean the basic idea is we need to
stave off
the attack as long as i can
probably like rook up six is the best
way to do it just let him take
for god's sakes
rook h69 f1 but then i
should be three now
and then this bishop is lost i think
he's going to sack his queen and he's
probably gonna swindle me but
at least i tried
okay we're playing to 15 games guys and
then i'm gonna sleep because i i have
charlie
in about five and a half hours and i'm
exhausted and i need to get a little
sleep
i've been calculating this i think
knight f3 wins
no
i got lucky a couple games nothing to
write home about
oh yes this ah this one i missed
crap come on daniel how can you miss
this
okay i'll just take another guy
probably f3 is good here
or actually wait queen five
is gonna double rocks and he's gonna
mate me
that's great that's just awesome
rook g6 probably is winning
i'm not sure
yeah probably it is
i shouldn't have done that either jesus
and so is my queen speaking of monsters
crap
should probably go here
walk in there
all right last one
last one guys last one last game let's
try to win it
and conventional
yeah that's pretty good
let's go here in the knight c3
g5 should be better for white here
hmm i could try to take it i honestly
could try to
freaking win the last one like a
champion
let's frickin do it in your honor ladies
and gentlemen i'm going to sack this
knight
danya style
in your honors they say in russian
this one's for you guys
hmm
this is very interesting
probably gonna lose but still in your
honor
here you might go e6 and that's the big
issue
ah but then oh oh my god
what's going on there whatever i'll just
do it
i will just do it
there's some incredible ideas here for
both sides
okay my idea was to go here
yeah this kind of falls into what i was
what i wanted
now i thought maybe i could just take
oh but he can take oh my god
that one i blundered yeah
there's nothing i can do here i think
or is there yeah i for i
i even saw it and then i forgot about it
damn
yeah that's over
okay you deserve that one
um maybe i can do this
it's still not over actually he made a
mistake somewhere i think
wait wait i'm still alive
i found an idea
that was a good game so
basically okay so this was all normal
let's go until the end so here
i sacked the knight weakening his king
and after e5 i of course missed the move
rook c5 i thought that
he's losing because if he moves the
knight then i take his other knight
and if he doesn't move the knight then i
take it rook c5 pins my queen here the
cool stuff starts
so i played bishop f5 in order to
intercept the rook i i renew the threat
of he takes f6
but the movie six is very very strong
here
um and one key detail is that after ef6
uh knight f6 i also have the move bishop
h7 which which wins the rook i saw this
one
but after he played e6 rook d1 queen c7
ef i
only calculated rook takes f5
this attacks the queen but now i have fg
and after rook g5 it turns out that i
get two rooks for the queen
um but he played a move i completely
missed knight f6 and here i thought i
was losing because the bishop on f5
seems to be lost and with that bishop
the whole position collapses him down a
piece but bishop g3 bishop e5 is an idea
that i found
in desperation and the idea
is that after e takes f5 i go rook to d6
and then i win his knight back okay
uh but he decides to play rook takes and
pawn takes so he gets two pieces for the
rook
he gets two pieces for the rook and
after rookie eight
i decided to make some lift for my king
h4
uh rookie six i give a check and here i
saw i think the brilliant idea
and it's the best move according to the
computer it's the only winning move
according to the computer
so i really gave everything i've got
here knight d5
now the idea is anybody's still hearing
nobody's chatting just making sure i'm
still live
i think people just start okay so knight
d5
knight takes d5 rook takes f7 and
despite him having three pieces
sorry just making sure despite him
having three pieces he's losing
there are there's no defense and there's
a couple of amazing lines here now i'm
threatening checkmate
he cannot give me the check on c1
because the queen is also guarding that
square
he has only one check rookie one but
after king h2 by king is safe
amazingly my king is safe uh he has no
checks and when he plays queen g6 this
is the freaking coup de grace
white to play and win ladies and
gentlemen this is the freaking move
and i when i saw this i almost flipped
out
roche rook h8 he cannot take with a
bishop he's got to take with the king
and he loses his queen
but that's not all after bishop e5 check
white still has to be careful
because if i block with g3 who can tell
me
how black defends okay white is still
winning here but what defensive try does
black have
rook h1 yeah rook h1 and knight f4
and okay rook v7 white is still
completely winning
but uh the move f4 i think defense
much easier because after bishop f4 rook
f4 knight f4 i can simply win the night
and win the game
so